i mean i'm sure everybody here is going
to cook with love but you know her love
is
one that i'm used to for the last 13
years so i think i'll be able to get it
she likes her food very salty but she's
aware that her preferences are not like
the mainstream preferences i've tried
food from her portion before like and
the amount of salt that she enjoys is
definitely not the amount of salt that i
don't think anybody wouldn't it's free
did you want to add some steaks to this
if i guess correctly then my reward is
that you have to clean out the bedroom
closet all by yourself wow but if i
guess incorrectly then i have to do it
all by myself
it's a bet let's make it happen
the three ingredients i chose today are
cheese olive oil and garlic i chose them
to level the playing field because
obviously swasti knows me really well
but the other two chefs may not if i
don't guess what these correctly i'm
just going to be disappointed in myself
so i am making a creamy garlic chicken
pasta i love pasta so i feel like if i
make something that he knows i love to
make he's gonna guess it so let's get
started with the pasta gonna throw some
penne up in here we have
garlic powder
paprika
italian seasoning
you can smell all the smells it's crazy
you guys it's gonna be good
fret not i have gloves and i have washed
my hands you've gotta put on some salted
pepper i love salt however i know not
everyone else likes the crazy amount of
salt that i like so we're gonna we're
gonna keep it simple okay now we got
some pepper
so i'm gonna get ready to cook this
chicken with olive oil
and now
it's time to place it in the pot all
right our chickens are cooked up on this
side so i'm gonna give them a little
flip look at that okay to finish this
chicken off we're actually going to
transfer it to the oven
so it's time to move on to our sauce
we're going to start with some butter
this pan is nice and flavorful
okay this is basically melted so i'm
going to place in the garlic and i'm
gonna let that kind of soften up a bit
in here i don't know if it's like
necessary but
i just feel like it tastes better i mean
it smells good because you get to smell
it by itself for a second i'm gonna add
in some tomatoes
some spinach
and now i'm going to kind of
mix it all together and let this
cook down a bit
it is time to grab our chicken i'm going
to slice them up look at that you can
see how juicy they are they're like
leaking on this board that's when you
know you've made a good chicken so i'm
grabbing my pasta it's been sitting here
for a second it's a little stuck up in
here
now i'm going to coat the pasta with the
sauce so that it all kind of comes apart
i don't understand how people plate
pasta so that it looks nice but i figure
it's okay you know maybe that's my
signature thing blob and center 10 will
know it's me now i'm going to sprinkle
some of ingredient number three
that parmesan cheese
and presto that's it
that's
creamy garlic chicken pasta
today i'm making spanakopita they are
these spinach hand pies
and i chose this recipe because it
incorporates the three
ingredients one being one of my favorite
cheeses feta a little bit of ricotta
cheese it highlights the garlic flavor
for sure and we'll be using a hefty
amount of olive oil so we're gonna get
started by using our olive oil and we'll
add in garlic
and then we're going to add in some
scallions and we're really just going to
make sure that these are like nice and
coated in the oil we don't really want
to fry them we just want to get them
nice and soft before we start adding all
of our spinach now we're going to add
our spinach just a little bit at a time
so that we can wilt it down and it'll
all fit and then i'm going to season the
spinach
with a little bit of salt and pepper
just to make sure we have seasoning
throughout last time i did this i didn't
add enough salt
and i got called out for it
and so we're not going to make that same
mistake again
and into this bowl we're going to make
the rest of our mixture i'm going to add
some feta
some ricotta
a little bit of mint
a little bit of dill
some parsley
and our egg
and we're gonna bring this mixture
together
and the feta will definitely bring some
saltiness
the ricotta is just going to bring a
really delicious creaminess and the rest
of the herbs are just going to be very
bright and delicious in here so now
we're going to
add our cheese mixture to our spinach
mixture so this is our filling and now
we're going to get our phyllo and we're
going to build these hand pies
this is sheets of phyllo dough
we'll go in with our favorite ingredient
a little bit of olive oil
great and then we'll put on our next
layer
[Music]
just plank it right on top
[Music]
and we're just going to keep doing this
until we have
about four layers nice and flaky pastry
we're going to cut this into four even
pieces four even rectangles
all right so then we're just going to
add
a pretty decent amount of our filling so
now i'm going to start at the top and
i'm going to start folding this down
into a triangle shape
[Music]
put it down on the sheet tray all right
now i'm going to pop these into the oven
for about 20-25 minutes so they get nice
and golden and crispy and then they'll
be ready for 10.
so i met tennant swasti so
like i think like four or five years ago
ten was rapping for i don't want to say
the name of the rapper but it was a
really big rapper and we were at his
house we were attending a party he was
rapping for him i liked his
actually his rhymes so i walked up to
him had a conversation that's when i met
the both of them and we've been friends
ever since today i'm going to be making
a chicken tikka roll um so the
ingredients that we were kind of going
off of were garlic olive oil and cheese
so to incorporate those ingredients we
have chicken tikka the marinade will
incorporate garlic a little bit of lemon
juice and a little bit of olive oil just
to kind of bind everything together on
the garlic parmesan fries we have the
garlic we have a little bit of garnish
on with some parsley and then we're
going to finally grate some parmesan
cheese on top of it as well so just to
be clear they're really good cooks but i
know 100 and i know they know that i am
the better cook out of our entire friend
circle no matter what all right let's
get started um we're going to make the
marinade for the chicken tikka roll so
you're going to start with plain yogurt
so next we're going to do the ginger
garlic paste in there
olive oil
garam masala salt to taste coriander
powder cumin powder kashmiri red chili
powder turmeric and a splash of lemon
juice and now you are going to combine
so you want to make it as smooth as
possible you want all that flavor to be
incorporated into the chicken
and then we'll bring in our chicken
and we're just going to marinate
everything together so at this stage
what we're going to do is we're going to
cover it put it in the fridge for about
two hours to marinate and then we'll
bring it back out and we'll grill them
up so now the chicken has been
marinating for two hours so we're gonna
go ahead and get our cast iron hot we're
gonna olive oil it up
always lay away from you
since we cut these really thin we're
gonna let them cook for about five to
ten minutes don't constantly flip let
one side cook and then flip it just one
time so we're gonna put these in the
oven for about another five more minutes
and we're gonna finish them off in there
now we're gonna move on to step two
we're gonna make the garlic parmesan
fries we're gonna just chop them up you
can do it however you feel comfortable
whatever size whatever length it really
goes up to you just make sure everything
is kind of uniform so it cooks correctly
perfect
so before we fry these we're going to
wash them in water get rid of the starch
and then we're going to fry them up so
we're going to fry up our french fries
bubbled
now that they're getting some color on
them we're going to take them off and
let them cool
all right now that they came out right
when they're hot you're going to want to
hit it with some salt and now we'll work
on our base for the garment parmesan
fries so you'll start with some minced
garlic parsley
and we'll do the salt
taste
white truffle oil
perfect
and then we're just going to toss them
in
and then just make sure everything is
tossed make sure you coat every french
fry so we're going to start to build
everything we're going to layer some
cabbage slaw
i know he likes himself
some extra chicken mint chutney on top
and we're gonna add
our garlic parmesan fries
i'm gonna grate some fresh parmesan
right on to the fries
here we go
wow this looks good
wow
okay so this is excellent i've got no
critiques of this dish i have a
suspicion as to who this could be based
on
the style of dish it is this is uh this
is indian cuisine um and i feel like i
know whose default would be that
i'm this is this is five star for me
this is better than much better than the
ones that you microwave because this is
very fresh considered without the
totality of the circumstances meaning
you haven't seen all three dishes
i don't have any educated guesses as to
who this might be i also ranked this
five stars um and that's not me being
diplomatic
viewers at home if you were here you
would know that all the food is
delicious how's the what the seasoning
level oh how's the seasoning level fire
for for both dishes i would say on point
it looks so nice that i almost don't
even want to you know ruin how it looks
this is incredible the sauce on the
pasta
is on point me personally i don't like
my meat to be too chewy so this chicken
is definitely done properly
this is definitely five star
level quality i know i've given
everything five stars and that's because
everything's been great but this is
incredible i now that i've had all three
i'm gonna go ahead and say that this is
my favorite dish this is when this is
over this is the one that i'm going to
want to devour immediately
i'm locking it in swasti
sri
cody
[Music]
[Applause]
guess who's not cleaning the bedroom
closet oh right i forgot about that you
forgot about the steaks
boom
[Music]
hi i'm cody yes
yes awesome awesome
thank you for making it for me my
pleasure yes i really appreciate it you
did a solid job here
[Music]
and does that that means that i was
correct about charis too you always get
it
[Applause]
nailed it man nailed it nailed it when
you were talking about the presentation
i was like this looks like trash even
back there when you're talking about it
was like what presentation this was like
that's well okay if you want to hear it
that's the story of our entire life like
she'll come out every day and be like
look in the mirror be like oh i was like
today i'd be like you seem to say
you look bomb every day
[Music]
you